[Music]
good morning Hank it's Thursday March
29th and I'm back home hooray hooray
hooray I know that my eye still looks
jacked up and the fact the matter is
that it's probably going to look jacked
up for a week or two but hopefully the
nerdfighters will understand Hank I've
got even more great news guess who I got
an email from yesterday you yes
sucker you accidentally included me on a
list of people you sent an email to
about mom yes you're gonna get punished
yes yes yes I mean I don't mean to sound
gleeful or anything it's just that I've
had a hard week and I look forward to
you having a hard week next week but how
will I punish you what should I do
should I make you whack something should
I make you sing something should I make
you eat something should I make you
snort something snorting is funny
snorting is always funny in other news
Hank when I saw your video yesterday I
got to thinking about fishing boat
proceeds and specifically whether or not
you and I can possibly acquire some I
proposed that by April of 2008 you and I
have found a way to put some amount of
fishing boat proceeds into our tax
return how hard can it be
I mean ostensibly all you need is a
fishing boat and then convince someone
to give you some proceeds for the
fishing boat right I'm not good at taxes
still can't see very good out of that I
you know Brotherhood 2.0 has a resident
mathematician in Daniel Biss I wish we
had a resident ophthalmologist could
someone get on that please
anyway Hank I need to help with the
nerdfighters to figure out what your
punishment is going to be because at the
moment I'm not feeling very creative
mostly I'm feeling like touching my eye
all the time be honest do you think it
looks better tell me the truth because I
really really really want it to get
better so help me help Hank get punished
by leaving your suggestions in comments
Hank I'll see you tomorrow hopefully out
of both eyes